well look you've done so much work as we
were just talking about i mean you know
you got this new movie press play which
i watched the trailer for and it looks
really sweet like it looks like a
tearjerker yes it is it is the guy i
have a very small part but the guy
greg bjorkman who directed it he came
out of that camp like the the fault in
our stars did you ever see that yeah
yeah yeah i loved that movie he was sort
of mentored by the guy behind that and
so it's very much of that energy where
like people are having these wonderful
conversations about life and it's about
love and and so it has that energy not
that it's the same movie in any way so
that's a great movie to reference well i
don't
know that they're probably apples and
oranges because i haven't seen that one
in a while but the feel yeah the feel is
there yeah
i think that's the genre perhaps maybe
they were trying to get and greg's a
wonderful guy and so uh i said sure i'll
do it so and look mike mckim talk from
veep he we were just quoting you
uh you know two emmy award nominations i
mean
you've done so many movies what does
that get you anyways but seriously you
know you've been nominated
i was nominated for a uh
i won a saturn award and my friends
immediately said well saturn than the
uranus award michael
you know that's the kind of [ __ ] that i
what's the saturn award if it was kind
of a sci-fi it was when smallville just
came out and it was like a newcomer best
newcomer and it was like i was i was
there with spielberg and i took a
picture with spielberg and it was the
saturn awards it was a nice thing
was the saturn awards its own ceremony
or was it inside the emmys no its own
awards its own thing did saturn cars run
this
i don't know okay i don't think so i
don't think they did okay i'm just
curious i didn't know